[Música]
el ministro de defensa de venezuela
general vladimir padrino lópez entregó
un balance de los enfrentamientos en la
frontera con colombia y anunció la
creación de una unidad militar especial
para la zona según el funcionario en 15
días de enfrentamientos el saldo sería
de 8 soldados venezolanos y 8
integrantes de grupos irregulares
muertos tenemos análisis de la crisis en
la zona límite
sexto día de audiencia de testigos en el
juicio contra el ex policía derecho a
bing por el asesinato de la familia cano
george floyd el 25 de mayo de 2020 el
jefe de policía de mineápolis aseguró
que yo vine no cumplió con las políticas
del departamento durante la detención y
el médico que certificó la defunción
declaró que fue por asfixia
en jordania la casa real dio por
terminada la crisis que sacudió el país
durante los últimos días mirada por
acusaciones contra el ex príncipe
heredero hamza bin husein de intentar
desestabilizar el reino hamza juró
fidelidad a su hermano el rey abdalá
segundo y se comprometió a acatar la
constitución jordana
bienvenidos a una nueva tarde de
información de américa latina y del
mundo aquí entradas 24 mi nombre es
liliana valencia venezuela confirmó la
muerte de ocho de sus militares el doble
de los que se tenía reportado hasta el
momento en los combates en la zona
fronteriza con colombia esto además de
nueve combatientes y 34 militares
heridos
así lo confirmó al ministro de defensa
de venezuela vladimir padrino lópez en
una rueda de prensa durante la cual
también sostuvo que venezuela creó una
unidad militar especial para una parte
de la frontera con colombia donde los
enfrentamientos completaron ya 16 días
alrededor de 6000 personas han resultado
desplazadas principalmente desde el
estado venezolano de apure hacia la
localidad de haro que está del otro lado
de la frontera
el presente se han dado nueve bajas de
estos grupos terroristas y
lamentablemente hemos sufrido la pérdida
de ocho compañeros de la fuerza armada
nacional bolivariana así como también 34
heridos que han recibido asistencia
médica en la red de salud militar ya más
de 21 han salido de alta
para analizar esta información nos
comunicamos con leonardo gonzález
coordinador del instituto de estudios
para el desarrollo y la paz indepaz que
se conecta con nosotros desde bogotá
colombia bienvenido a france 24 y
cuéntenos el gobierno colombiano
sostiene que las fuerzas militares
venezolanas se están enfrentando a la
insurgencia de la guerrilla de la farc y
a facciones del ejército de liberación
nacional ln por el control del
narcotráfico en la zona algo que el
gobierno de nicolás maduro niega
considera usted que las acusaciones de
colombia al respecto tienen fundamento
digamos que son parciales aquí no
solamente es el control del narcotráfico
son diferentes disputas territoriales
que se están presentando por varias
riquezas no solamente el narcotráfico
también está la minería especialmente
mina artesanal minería ilegal es en esto
en zona de el estado de bolívar
contrabando de gasolina también sabemos
pues obviamente que está la oxy en el
lado colombiano entonces hay disputas
territoriales de grandes riquezas
se está dando en estos momentos no
solamente está lln también hay dos
facciones de las farc en frente 10 y el
frente 28 y además la segunda
marquetalia todos pues detrás también de
narcotráfico y de estas riquezas que
tiene toda esta zona que obviamente es
una frontera que lleva más de 40 años
con presencia de grupos armados ilegales
con presencia paramilitar de ln de las
farc una frontera porosa en donde entran
y salen los diferentes grupos armados y
es que tiene está este enfrentamiento y
está disputa territorial
bueno cuéntanos el presidente venezuela
nicolás maduro le pido ayuda a la onu
para limpiar la frontera de minas
antipersonales ese es un mensaje en
contra de colombia
hoy también cuéntenos si cesaba de
presencia de minas antipersonales o
víctimas de las mismas en esta zona es
una realidad las minas antipersona están
en diferentes zonas del país y la
frontera no es una excepción es
necesario que exista un diálogo no
solamente
de venezuela con naciones unidas sino
también con el gobierno colombiano para
poder limpiar esta zona de minas
antipersonas que son las víctimas
especialmente de la sociedad civil
quienes caen en estas minas y son de
venezuela y de colombia esto es una una
práctica que se ha venido llevando desde
hace ya varios años tanto en el estado
de bolívar el estado de apure pero
también en obviamente en arauca
bueno si bien el flujo migratorio en la
frontera colombo-venezolana es constante
durante los últimos años en estos 15
días los desplazados serían más de 6000
representa esto un nuevo riesgo de
emergencia humanitaria y también
sanitaria por la pandemia y también que
tendría que pasar para que finalizar
estos enfrentamientos es un riesgo el
que se está presentando en estos
momentos sanitario ya como ustedes lo
dicen son más de 6000 personas que han
estado transitando que son desplazados
aproximadamente 3.000 son de venezuela
1700 menores de edad y 200 adultos
mayores es una crisis de alta de alto
grado el que se está viviendo en estos
momentos entonces lo que hay que hacer
es tener diálogo en estos momentos entre
los dos gobiernos para la atención
humanitaria de los diferentes con
nacionales bueno y por último también
preguntarle si estos nuevos desplazados
que vienen principalmente del estado
venezolano y apuré podrían acogerse a
las nuevas medidas dictadas por el
presidente colombiano iván duque de
acoger y regularizar a muchos aún
porcentaje de los migrantes venezolanos
o cuál sería la situación migratoria de
estos desplazados se deben acoger y se
debe tratar con con las normas
internacionales de migración que se que
se están dando en estos momentos
rechazar los puestos obviamente no se
pueden ningún en ningún momento en
ningún medida y el gobierno colombiano
de acogerlos así como también el
gobierno venezolano acusó a muchos
desplazados colombianos en su momento
entonces es necesario tener una amplitud
humanitaria para todos los venezolanos
que están siendo desplazados pues
agradecemos la opinión de leonardo
gonzález coordinador del instituto de
estudios para el desarrollo y la paz
indepaz desde bogotá colombia y
continuamos con información de eeuu
porque continúa el juicio contra el ex
policía derecha bing según el testimonio
del jefe de policía de mineápolis acuse
el acusado rompió las reglas y el código
de ética de las autoridades durante el
violento arresto que terminó con la
muerte de georg floyd
me daría arredondo le dijo al jurado
haberse sentido alarmado tras conocer
los vídeos del arresto que circularon
por redes sociales aseguró que las
prácticas de chavín durante el
procedimiento no hacen parte del
entrenamiento ni en los valores que se
le imparte a los oficiales de policía
de otra parte brad por la game field el
médico que declaró la muerte del
afroamericano el 25 de mayo de 2020
sostuvo que la asfixia fue la causa más
probable del fallecimiento de floyd
cuando cree usted que debería haber
cesado esta restricción cuando cree que
debió detenerse
videos
una vez que el señor floyd y esto se
basa en mi observación de los vídeos
una vez que el señor floyd dejó de
resistirse y ciertamente una vez que
estuvo angustiado y tratando de expresar
eso en ese momento debería haber
terminado de ninguna manera es algo que
sea parte de nuestra capacitación y
ciertamente no es parte de nuestra ética
o nuestros valores
y este 11 de abril tendrá lugar un super
domingo electoral en américa latina'
pero elegir a un nuevo presidente
después de tener cuatro mandatarios en
cuatro años ecuador realizará la segunda
vuelta de las presidenciales que no
escaparon de ser acusadas de fraude por
parte del candidato ya q pérez quien
resultó tercero en la preferencia de
voto y la jornada la completará la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones
regionales en cuatro departamentos de
bolivia
cambiamos ahora de información porque
jordania la familia real dice que la
crisis política que se desató este fin
de semana ha sido superada el principe
hamza en el medio hermano del rey abdalá
segundo que se encontraba en arresto
domiciliario acusado de sedición juró
lealtad ante el monarca en una carta
firmada y que ha sido distribuida por el
palacio más en el siguiente informe
después de un fin de semana de tensión
en la familia real de jordania el
príncipe de hansa parece haber dado
marcha atrás el medio hermano del rey
había sido puesto bajo arresto
domiciliario el fin de semana junto con
otras 16 personas por presuntamente
conspirar para desestabilizar el país
pero ahora el palacio asegura que la
situación a veces calado y hamza firmó
una declaración en la que jura lealtad
ante el monarca voy a permanecer fiel al
legado de mis ancestros siguiendo sus
pasos leal a su camino y a su mensaje y
a su majestad
antes el sábado el príncipe hamza había
publicado un vídeo en el que acusaba a
la dirigencia jordana de corrupción pero
negaba a ser parte de cualquier complot
los eeuu la mayoría de potencias del
golfo y la liga árabe se apresuraron
para manifestar su apoyo al rey abdulá
ya su gobierno que es visto como un
pilar de estabilidad en la región with
you' valoramos su integridad y visión y
como dijimos durante el fin de semana de
manera muy clara el rey tiene nuestro
apoyo total el principe hamza es una voz
crítica del liderazgo del país y en 2004
el rey abdulá le arrebató el título de
príncipe heredero
el presidente de israel rubén rivlin
afirmó que no es posible conformar una
coalición de gobierno tras el primer día
de conversaciones con los partidos
políticos del país el jefe estado
aseguró que tras cuatro elecciones en
dos años la democracia israelí está
exhausta y no existe consenso entre los
partidos para sacar al país del
estancamiento político el primer
ministro benjamin netanyahu busca la
manera de permanecer en el poder justo
en momentos en los que se retomó un
juicio en su contra por corrupción
durante la audiencia de este lunes la
fiscalía acusó al premier de abuso de
poder por haber presuntamente obtenido
beneficios indebidos de grandes medios
de comunicación por su parte netanyahu
denunció una cacería de brujas en su
contra
la apertura de investigaciones en contra
del primer ministro fue en contra de la
ley no de cualquier ley sino de la que
requiere el permiso del fiscal general
para la apertura de la investigación es
un permiso que nunca fue otorgado sólo
ni ton
no la vamos porque hicieron eso es una
cacería de brujas ellos no investigaron
un crimen no buscaron un crimen su
persiguieron a un hombre me persiguieron
a mí
en hip sutil pasamos a europa porque
varios países comenzaron una nueva etapa
de de sesca la miento de las medidas
impuestas para contener la pandemia el
gobierno de reino unido confirmó la
reapertura del comercio no esencial a
partir del 12 de abril de acuerdo con un
anuncio del primer ministro boris
johnson simultáneamente en grecia y
portugal iniciaron este lunes a libios
al comercio en el caso de grecia de
grecia la desescalada llega a pesar de
que los contagios continúan repuntando
natalia plazas nos cuenta más en el
siguiente informe
el comercio no esencial en reino unido
vuelve a tener un respiro a medida que
las vacunaciones avanzan rápidamente y a
la par que las cifras de contagio
descienden el primer ministro anunció
una nueva desescalada a partir de la
próxima semana
james james estaremos abriendo tiendas
gimnasios zoológicos campos vacacionales
servicio de cuidado personal como
peluquerías y por supuesto terrazas al
aire libre y hostelería al aire libre de
todo tipo el lunes 12 de abril yo mismo
iré al pub cautelosamente pero
irreversiblemente llevaron al pinta de
cerveza a mis labores en gay pride corp
y de baile
johnson también indicó que el gobierno
busca un sistema con el que se pueda
certificar la exposición de los
ciudadanos al virus para poder reanudar
los grandes eventos abrió también la
puerta a que los viajes internacionales
se reanuden antes de verano en grecia
donde los hospitales aún enfrentan una
fuerte presión y los casos siguen al
alza las autoridades dieron luz verde a
la reapertura de los pequeños negocios
eléctricos tramix hoy hablé con el rigor
felizmente el mercado ha vuelto a abrir
y podemos ver cierto movimiento espero
que se mantengan las medidas y que las
personas mantendrán su distancia con el
fin de que el gobierno no tome más
medidas y no nos encierre de nuevo hemos
llamarles unidos debe votarlo y en
portugal las restricciones impuestas en
enero continúan relajándose desde este
lunes terrazas de cafeterías y
restaurantes vuelven a abrir también lo
hacen museos pequeñas tiendas y
gimnasios entre otros establecimientos
el país vivió en enero el peor aumento
de casos registrado en todo el mundo
ahora aunque los contagios se ralentizan
cines centros comerciales y otros
negocios no esenciales permanecerán
cerrados al menos dos semanas más
y finalizamos con una colega periodista
en la ciudad de moscú que en el momento
de realizar un informe en directo para
una cadena local fue víctima de un robo
en vivo y en directo vean esto
el golden retriever tomó a la
comunicadora por sorpresa y le arrebató
el micrófono que confundió con un
juguete cuando ella se aprestaba a
ofrecer un reporte sobre el clima
la presentadora corrió tras el canino y
posteriormente se tomó el momento con
humor al final de su reporte hizo las
paces con el inocente ladrón y le conde
y le le concedió una pequeña entrevista
son cosas que millones
con estas imágenes finalizamos entradas
24 ustedes pueden continuar con más en
nuestra página web tras 24 punto com
quédense con nosotros tenemos más para
ustedes estos france24
[Música]